agathe quel est votre plus grosse contre
qualité votre goût ma plus grosse honte
j'étais au lycée
et c'était la première fois où j'allais
enfin pouvoir aller dormir chez mon
amoureux de l'époque non qu'ils allaient
me présenter à sa famille il s'appelait
charles
les présentations se passe très bien on
dîne tout se passe très bien et là d'un
moment d'aller au lit ouais donc moi
j'étais tout excité à l'idée de dormir
dans la dans la chambre de mon petit
copain
non mais un décalage j'avais 15 ans j'ai
commencé à contrôler et donc on arrive
on monte à étages pour aller se coucher
et là sa maman me dit agathe jeter
préparer la chambre d'amis away très
bien sûr aidé en fait c'était la chambre
qui était mitoyenne celle de mon
amoureux dont elle met une porte il
communiquer entre eux et de l avais
déplacer les meubles de la maison pour
bloquer les portes genre pour empêcher
qu'on se rejoignent donc dans un hyper
mal à l'aise je n'avais pas non plus
j'aurais respecter bref finalement la
nuit arrive les parents vont se coucher
on finit par se rejoindre et on s'est
fait grillé et j'ai jamais aussi 11 2%
en février
c'est à dire comment couper bas par la
maman qu'entendu d'une entrevue en train
de faire quoi on n'était pas non plus
dans des positions à brakel qu'elle
était tenue non